in 2018 a truly original horror film
called a quiet place premiered at South
by Southwest the buzz was fast and
furious much like the film's truly
terrifying creatures next year we'll be
getting a sequel to a quiet place here's
everything we know so far
a few weeks after the US release of a
quiet place on April 6 2018 Paramount
Pictures announced that a sequel was
officially happening this wasn't
terribly surprising news after all the
film was a monster hit right out of the
gate it also happened to be directed by
John Krasinski a multi-talented actor
best known for his turn in the office
we're in the office earlier talking to
Wallace did I come up at all well we did
talk about how handsome Krasinski also
co-starred and co-wrote the screenplay
for a quiet place ultimately he helmed a
thoroughly engaging Fright Fest that was
basically begging for a follow-up albeit
quietly
the sequel was originally set to
premiere on May 15th 2020 but the powers
that be moved up that date to March 20th
2020 long story short we don't have to
wait much longer to see the next
installment as of the making of this
video the film doesn't have an official
title in a july 2019 twitter post
actor and director John Krasinski shared
a slate from production that simply read
part two so there's that but as of now
the film's title could be pretty much
anything it could be a quiet place to
keep quiet and even quieter place a
quiet place to return to Shh the
possibilities are endless expect to see
some familiar faces in the sequel in
early 2019 it was confirmed that actress
Emily Blunt John Krasinski's wife in
real life would be returning to play
Evelyn Abbott and there's more good news
co-star Millicent Simmons and Noah Joop
will be back to play Reagan and Markus
Abbott so if you've been eager to catch
up with the Abbott family you're in luck
however it's still unclear whether
Krasinski will be appearing in the film
we're guessing not
[Music]
the world of a quiet place is well it's
very very quiet
[Music]
except when it's not
throughout the first film we pretty much
stick with the Abbott family though we
do meet another ill-fated survivor it's
a very brief very brutal moment but it
shows us that the Abbott's aren't alone
as John Krasinski told deadline in May
2018
the thing that I loved in the movie was
the question of who was on the other end
of those fires when the father lights
the fire and in the distance those other
fires light up how did those people
survive looks like we may find out
there's going to be some new totally
panicked faces in the sequel in March
2019
Killian Murphy of peaky blinders was
reportedly in talks to join the cast
husband spirit team in June 2019 it was
announced that Atlanta actor Brian Tyree
Henry was also cast in the film but
scratch that deadline reported in August
2019 the Jamin Honsou was replacing him
due to henri having a scheduling
conflict as we mentioned John Krasinski
didn't just direct and star in a quiet
place he also co-wrote the screenplay
although writers Scott back in Brian
woods are credited with the first film's
original story presents key ultimately
rewrote the script this time around
Krasinski is the director and the sole
screenwriter according to IMDB that's an
exciting development and we can't wait
to see what he's cooking up for us
intriguingly he told the New York Times
in January 2019 I do have sort of a
parental feeling about this movie and I
don't want a quiet place to turn into an
action movie where 400 people have
machine guns or did I give away the
ending to the sequel okay we would
totally watch that so what exactly do we
know about the ghastly creatures in a
quiet place not a whole lot there
presumably extraterrestrials and they
obviously have extra sensitive hearing
oh and they've wiped out most of
humanity they are kind of a big deal
will we be learning more about these
vicious jerks in the sequel before
leaving the project actor Brian Tyree
Henry dropped a rather tantalizing
morsel in June 2019 he told the observer
I think that we're also going to get a
few answers to the origin of where and
how this whole thing happened I think
that people want to know that but I
think you're just going to see
another side of it more of humanity that
survived this thing in the next story
that's all we know about the sequel
right now John Krasinski and his cohorts
have remained remarkably tight-lipped
about the upcoming horror film which is
really rather appropriate isn't it check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]